hahaha how's it going bread welcome back
to summer to cry affair it's been a
while say there's a lot of stuff to play
now I think the stairway I don't [ __ ]
know I'm gonna play all of them anyways
you're scared bro I know it's late
was there behind you
Silent Hill musica that's how I get up -
all right
chapter one ah I have no idea about that
that's all good all right father all
right / - oh can I take you with me
Beauty I am I know but can I take you
with me
alright god damn it I hate when I can't
do it
alright actually let's go I'm Nisha
styling this [ __ ] let's go like this
[Music]
all right so fado I'll make you proud
bro I don't need to do this right now
all right
[Music]
the thing is oh it's so dark
oh I don't like oh [ __ ] all right oh god
I hate him so much I didn't even get the
same ah [ __ ] me I gotta read through
everything
ah I hate the chainsaw guy he's [ __ ]
worse all right
[Music]
really all right hey I like it face it
sir but not today are you [ __ ]
kidding me
that is not humanly possible you keep
doing this to me cry affair you keep
being funny but I opened another one
the whole are come on
whoa that was a close escape I don't
know what I feel about this what is this
a flare oh [ __ ] me the flare scares so
much all right
oh all right let's get up here
I forgot how awesome this - hey okay
okay okay holy [ __ ] my room which how
did I get you to here
I run that's how I did it half life it's
a fart up this photo take the gun with
you make sure you get out of here
all right so far oh thanks bro
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] are you dad blood
everywhere
fantastic basement cake a coffee cup
alright alright alright alright alright
we can be friends we can be friends we
can be friends we can be friends we can
be friends we can't just get a [ __ ]
idiot all right what do we got a soap
more stuff more soap basement let's go
[Music]
nail let sure nothing bad right ov Akio
don't make me kill you what he's in here
hello can you die please let's roll
today but if you had has got a baby baby
baby baby it's dark
alright where's the door I'm gonna sit
her and pee a little bit my face [ __ ] oh
thank god
Stefano it was terrible I can finally
save at least [ __ ]
that was [ __ ] MLG stuff in there
alright Stefano tell me I am surprised
he made it here I'll a lot of things
won't go easy for him now what not ESA's
if I don't are you kidding me
that was far from [ __ ] easy
holy [ __ ] alright yeah well I'm geared
as [ __ ] right now um no oh no chapter 2
oh [ __ ] me hello creatures of the night
don't be nice ha
what happened oh no not you not you not
you not you oh [ __ ] are you doing oh
[ __ ] I hate em all right Nate fat fat
fat that's right you back the [ __ ] up or
Emma how God did someone just pass
through here I don't know
nice flying nice all right don't make me
Kelly oh it's [ __ ] kidding oh I
killed your brother look how much I give
a [ __ ]
alright anyone else what are you doing
out of my way my Luck's aiming choice
fold
merlok [ __ ] you let's make [ __ ] kill
things I'm dropping you actually I don't
I don't need somebody [ __ ] lying
things and before a holy [ __ ]
kinda Dickie oh wait how did how does
that even possible
[ __ ] ah Jesus Christ
oh good I was dust no no no bad game bad
game bad game bad game by game by game
bad game by game but yet let me love you
to bug error retry [ __ ] you
stop cried crash it crashed alright so
it kept crashing
so I don't know it doesn't work
why should I do so we will try Scrolls
of Scheib Oh sounds nice Shia moon is a
good place to go whenever you want some
titty rubbin temple of war defense not
so bad
I got a lantern well it's a temple
awesome color what am I doing here
a Malaysia style I picked up a syringe
under the pillar this looks very nice
I like whoa
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] Bay oh my what happened
to you
Oh No be gentle with me I don't like
this
Wow don't kill me holy [ __ ] what am I
going I don't even know Bros this is
[ __ ] creeping me out man
no no bad room
oh my oh my god huh [ __ ]
no no who did idol me to do it Jerry
I live in Oh Jerry is okay
Oh another dead person on a gun it's
empty
[ __ ] I don't worry which way
[ __ ] it's stuck
all right Sophie oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
Sophie shell oh holy [ __ ]
all right I got a spade Spada I have a
spotter ah [ __ ] me bra it's [ __ ]
creepy as hell is shake so fun ha ha
and that's Vinick you're beautiful oh my
god you dude what's going on hey you
don't know I did I don't know anything
okay my god did someone get dragged here
Oh what am i doing okay I don't know
anything just don't kill me
whoever disturbs the grave of Kings
shall open the great stars oh well that
was me
I did that son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
other spot it worked all right cool I'm
glad this spot I got sacrificed everyone
is a good oh [ __ ]
hello oh I use the stairs
oh hello dead people very nice
Oh more dead people fantastic
another dead pace it just keeps getting
better and imagine huh well whatever
watch no no come on Jack wait I'm sure
I'm friendly
I'm friend I like your sweater actually
hey I like your face too plastic surgery
it's really cool and your face double in
your face triple in your face all what
you're gonna do slappa slappa why does
he never die there we go step on you
don't even have a face how are you live
in the first place
Slava oh I killed your friend you don't
even have heads seriously what all right
later dudes stupid [ __ ] those were
my friend oh there were my friends what
the hell is going on oh [ __ ] it's the
father I don't like this
all right breasts it looks like I will
have to end it here shame is a little
buggy because there are a really cool
custom stories I hope I will have it
fixed for the next time I'll talk to
someone about it but anyway like afraid
if you enjoyed subscribe and another day
and I'll see you next episode are they
as in Britain okay like that
what is that face oh yeah that's right
yeah